[موسيقى]
بالإضافة إلى كمية هذا النقص
الذي وجد أنه نادر جدًا
يجد العظام على الرغم من الحفريات
المواقع الأثرية مرة كل 10 سنوات
من خلال إيجاد عام 2012 وجدنا آخر
الجسم في عام 2022 لديه مثل هذه الكتلة
من العظام إنه فريد حقًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضع في اعتبارك ما يمكننا فعله
في محاولة لمعرفة من أين أتوا
ما هي المنطقة التي هم فيها
لقد اختبرت هذا بفضل جرعة
السترونشيوم الذي سنجده على مستوى
الأسنان ، على سبيل المثال روماتيزم
مختلف الأشكال الموجودة في
الكمية النسبية تختلف أيضًا وفقًا لـ
المنطقة
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد أحد اليوم لدينا أكثر من
وعائي ليس لدينا صورة
الفترة إما الصورة لم تكن موجودة
لذلك لن يجلب أي شيء على الإطلاق
تفعل ولكن أجدها مثيرة للاهتمام
لإعادة إنتاج وجه جندي من
حرب واترلو